sept cent cinquante huit mille bébés
sont nés en france en 2018
ces douze mille naissances de moins
qu'en 2010 est la tendance semble
s'installer dans l'hexagone
pour la quatrième année consécutive la
natalité est en baisse passant de 819
millions essence en 2014 à 750 8000 en
la dernière baisse significative de la
natalité en france remonte aux années 70
regardez après un rebond les naissances
dégringolait entre 1971 et 1976 passant
de 916 mille naissances à 747 millions à
court terme
cette baisse de naissance représente une
économie pour la collectivité
à moyen terme les choses se compliquent
moins de bébés dans les années 70 et les
raisons sont multiples déjà la crise
économique mondiale n'aide pas vraiment
les français à envisager l'avenir
mais surtout cette décennie marque un
tournant dans la vie des femmes la
pilule et l'avortement sont légalisés à
quelques années d'intervalle
désormais les grossesses ne sont plus
subi mais choisit ces chiffres sont
révélateurs toujours entre 1971 et 1976
le taux de fécondité soit le nombre
moyen d'enfants par femme passe de 2,5 à
1,8 en 1976 sur le plateau de l'émission
aujourd'hui madame des femmes des fonds
des mêmes leur choix de ne pas avoir
d'enfants donc j'ai choisi de ne pas
avoir d'enfant parce que je voulais
assumer ma liberté et me réalisés faire
le choix de l'indépendance plutôt que
celui de la maternité ni des mal perçue
dans les années soixante dix où ce très
mal pourquoi on se servant des enfants
je trouve qu'à la menace est pas mal à
mon avis c'est pas bien pourquoi je
crois que c'est sont pas heureuses
millions à leur manque quelque chose
wheeler en pratique elle pense à rien
elle a rien dans sa petite tête
si la population veut pas après ça va ça
va finir appuyé le il y aura plus de
comment dire de population est la panne
où on emploie les femmes responsables de
la fin du loup c'en est trop pour la
présidente du planning familial de
l'époque et donc personne un homme ne
pense jamais à dire
avez vous des enfants en lui demande
toujours avec calme et y est faite à une
femme on lui pose toujours cette
question avez vous des enfants on la
pense pondeuses pour relancer les
naissances le gouvernement de l'époque
renforce la politique nataliste en
multipliant notamment les aides en
faveur de la famille aujourd'hui malgré
une natalité de nouveau en baisse la
france reste toujours le pays le plus
fécond de l'union européenne
[Musique]